[Musique]
c'est le temps des parts et d'huîtres
que les festivités commencent pour y
manger des huîtres à la maison entre
amis c'est vraiment festif c'est
vraiment plaisant pour moi
personnellement des grands plaisirs
c'était vraiment de l'ouvrir et de la
manger sont sous le choc
pour les préparer chez soi il faut
s'équiper d'un bon couteau pour vous on
en test kenz l'épicerie a organisé un
petit pas réduite avec daniel note qing
grand champion mondial ouvreur d'huîtres
et frédéric chabot des agneaux
industrielle la partie ce moment qu'une
lame qui à un moment où on devrait être
capable d'ouvrir 18 je recommande pas de
faire avec un couteau
le couteau est trop pointu look tôt et
trop coupable et risque de blessure son
père élevé nos experts ont classé les
couteaux selon les matériaux utilisés
la longueur ou la forme de la lame et
dimanche pour tester les couteaux nous
avons choisi trois variétés d'huîtres de
tailles différentes avec les couteaux la
plupart des modèles sont munis de lames
qui font toute la longueur du couteau un
et où selon lui la lame en acier rentrer
complètement dans le gard le march
alors ça c'est vous donne assez de
tournage je vois que tu vivras menu
yasui alors moi j'aime toujours avoir un
petit neige pour me protéger la main
alors ça rentre quand même assez bien le
voir frédéric il ya une garde qu'on
appelle ce à quoi on appelle pour les
gens qui ont moins l'habitude ça peut
être pratique souvent ceux qui ont peu
ses habitudes ça les encombrent bien
pour avoir la garde ses messages et
nyala non non je n'ai le grand
différence est que si vous avez un côté
qui coupe un côté plus épais pour la
rigidité actif du couteau d'un côté plus
minces pour aller couper le muscle et
pour les huîtres de se tasser
c'est un bon couteau
les deux couteaux ont bien rempli leur
rôle même chose pour look so de couteau
avec l'âme légèrement courbé ont
impressionné nos testeurs donc cela
c'est le modèle typique qu'on appelle
new haven qu'une légère courbe vers la
pointe
ok ce qui permet d'avoir un meilleur
levier 8 vraiment en caoutchouc nous
sommes avoir une bonne prise et ce
modèle si beaucoup de lacs ailleurs dans
le sud utilise une huître qui est formé
avec sa veste et nous rêver parce que
les huîtres sont très grands très fort
très difficile d'ouvrir
moi je n'utilise pas souvent des
couteaux comme ça mais je suis une
pression le modèle dean kitchen a
surpris daniel
[Musique]
en fait quand même pu blesser notre
championnat mais ça se peut même si
c'est même avec deux amis mais la presse
de 100000 tu dois toujours être vigilant
vigilance
la poignée vraiment étrange c'est très
bon j'ai besoin de beaucoup de stock
mais de façon générale c'est pas très
confortable
les protège mains de ses couteaux honte
encombrer nos testeurs ça remplace le
linge manager en place le matériel et le
couteau celui ci est restée unique
unique et je crois trop dangereux et l
as saint denis important avant cette
gamme il dit très très pointu oui je
peux pas faire l'opération au complet
faut la sortir après il faut la sortir
on attend trop gros ok c'est pas fait
pour nous nos grosses vis tu dois tenir
ce côté jusqu'en juste combien la
question toujours c est ce que c'est
nécessaire deux couteaux pliants à 35 $
chacun nous ont laissés perplexes
donc oui c'est super important de barils
à l'âme mais c'est lui le la barre sûrs
en confiance vraiment pas grand chose si
c est ce que ça vaut la peine de
l'essayer où en est ce que jésus tout
chemin
est ok non si l'on n'oublie sonne c'est
déjà croche
déjà proche avec après une huître de 7 à
bord cela la rate même éliminé l'opinel
a mieux fait son travail
ce salon bien trempé vols sont prudents
la lame courbe
ok on arrête ça passe bien mais si je
dois ma chère que toi à 8 que je veux
garder longtemps que je vais aimer
j'achète pour lui non le manche en inox
de ce modèle manquais d'adhérence debout
victorinox avec leurs longues lames sont
conçus plutôt pour les gros huîtres je
crois que c'est non mais pour les
huîtres de la sud de l'amérique thénard
qui sera huîtres foie gras qui a besoin
de beaucoup de torsion donc ses couteaux
là se sont davantage pour 18 pressé il
sait pas le couteau pour l'universalité
je peux quand même deux couteaux
spécialisés avec poignées ergonomiques
ont bien fonctionné mais demande du
doigté et de l'expérience
en cela le voeu que spontanément ou
choisi si votre préféré
ok c'est pas le mail à mes précieuses
les deux c'est le même type de l'homme
c'est la lame new haven qu'apple les
couteaux courbé sur les gagnants
personnellement je préfère le manche de
celui là et j'aime toujours quand même
un petit gars de mon côté sécuritaire
[Musique]